hey everyone it's Sarah with registered
nurse rn.com and in this video I want to
demonstrate how to assess vital signs on
an infant so let's get started when
assessing vital signs on an infant you
want to start with the most non-invasive
Vital Signs first while the infant is
calm and resting therefore first you're
going to check the respirations followed
by the heart rate then the temperature
the weight the length the head
circumference and then the chest
circumference before you assess the
infant's vital signs you want to make
sure that you gather your supplies so
what you're going to need is an infant
size stethoscope followed by a measuring
tape a thermometer a scale and a watch
to count with and you want to make sure
that you sanitize everything that you're
going to use on that infant before and
after use and of course perform hand
hygiene before beginning first we're
going to check respirations and we're
going to do that first while the infant
is laying here nice and calm so we get
an accurate reading and a normal
respiratory rate in an infant is about
30 to 60 breaths per minute so before we
even start counting respirations we want
to look at that infant and we want to
make sure that they're not in any
respiratory distress so one way we can
tell is we can look at the nose infants
love to breathe through their nose so we
were checking their nostrils and we're
looking for nasal flaring and if you see
that that's not a good sign also you
want to look at that chest and you want
to look for anything like chest
retractions and what that looks like it
literally looks like the skin has just
been pulled over the ribs and you can
see the ribs very well and this infant
does not have either of those things in
addition you want to look at the
infant's skin color and make sure it's
appropriate for their skin tone and that
you don't see any signs and symptoms of
cyanosis so to count respirations what
we're going to do is we're going to
count for one full minute the rise in
the fall of the chest Now with an adult
you probably remember that if the rate
was regular we could count for 30
seconds and multiply by two well this
isn't the case with infant you're going
to do it for one full minute because
infant's breathing pattern is irregular
they have what's called periodic
breathing where they'll breathe and then
they'll stop for a second so we're going
to count for one full minute and we're
looking at that rise and that fall of
the chest and infants like to breathe
abdominally so if you're having trouble
what you could do is you could lightly
place your hand on the chest and feel
the rise in the fall but you want to be
careful not to disturb the infant and
get them crying so I'll demonstrate and
I'll count with each rise and with each
fall just to give you an example so here
we go one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten so you want to
count that rise in that fall for one
full minute and then document that
number so his respirations were 38 which
again is normal because a normal rate is
about 30 to 60 breaths per minute to
count the heart rate you want to make
sure that you're using the appropriate
size diaphragm and bell and we have an
infant here so we're using an infant
size and for an infant who is less than
a month a normal heart rate is about 100
to 190 beats per minute and this can
vary if the infant is crying or if
they're sleeping now if the infant is
over one month that heart rate goes down
a little bit the normal ranges it's
about 90 to 180 beats per minute so to
count the heart rate what we're going to
do is we're going to use the apical
pulse we're not going to use the radial
pulse like how we do in adults so to
find the apical pulse what you want to
do is you want to find the fourth
intercostal space now on an adult
remember it was the fifth fossil space
at the microvicular line but for an
infant it's at the fourth intercostal
space lateral to the midclavicular line
so you want to find the clavicle and
then we have the breast bone and we're
going to go down and we're going to fill
in between those little ribs and we're
going to go to the fourth space so
there's one
two
three
four and then we're going to just go
lateral to the midclavicular line so
we're going to go about right here and
this is about where the apical pulses on
our infant and we're going to place our
stethoscope there and we're going to
listen for one full minute now an
infant's heart rate
can have sinus arrhythmia where it's
irregular because their heart rate is
can be affected with the respirations
where their heart rate will actually
speed up and slow down with respiration
so that's where you want to count for
one full minute now counting an infant's
heart rate can be difficult because it
is fast and one thing that I have found
that definitely helps me is I find that
heart rate and then I like tap my finger
along with that heart rate and count and
our infant's heart rate here is about
142. to check the temperature in the
infant we're going to check it via the
axillary route so we're going to place
the thermometer tip in the armpit of the
infant and I've already placed a little
protective sheath over the thermometer
so a normal temperature in an infant can
vary anywhere between 97.5 to 99.3
degrees Fahrenheit to take the
temperature make sure that you turn the
thermometer on and then you're going to
place the tip of the thermometer deep
inside the fold of the armpit and then
you're just going to put the arm down
and you're going to wait for the
thermometer to beep to tell you the
reading okay our thermometer is beeping
so it is done and the reading is
99.1 so we would document this and this
Falls within normal range to obtain a
weight on an infant you want to remove
the infant's clothing and any soiled
diaper a dry diaper can be used so place
the infant on the scale and obtain the
weight
here this infant weighs 10 pounds 2
ounces so you'd want to document that
way and then look at the infant's
previous weights this patient weighed 8
pounds at Birth and now at this two-week
appointment they weigh 10 pounds 2
ounces so that is a very good weight
gain from their birth weight to measure
length what you want to do is you want
to lay the baby on a surface that you
can Mark you'll need a PIN for this and
you may need someone's help to help you
measure the baby because you're going to
measure from head to heel so lay the
baby back you'll want to put their head
midline like this and then just mark
their head and then you want to take the
leg and extend it outward like this make
sure it's nice and extended you may have
to work with them a little bit and then
Mark it at the heel
and a normal length in an infant is
about 18 to 22 inches and then we're
going to gently lift the baby up so
we're going to measure this and we're
actually measuring this in inches and
the infant is 22 inches to measure head
circumference you're going to need a
measuring tape and you want one that
measures in centimeters now a normal
head circumference in an infant is about
33 to 38 centimeters and what we want to
do is we want to place the tape measure
around the largest diameter of the head
so to do that we're going to place a
little bit above the eyebrows and then
we're going to wrap that around and
place it around the most prominent part
at the back of the head so let's do that
so gently just lift the head up and put
the measuring tape behind it
and then pull your measuring tape around
remove his head a little bit
and let's see what we get
and his head circumference is about 37
centimeters to measure chest
circumference you want to get your
measuring tape again you'll be measuring
this in centimeters and you're going to
take it and use the nipple line as your
guide so you're going to wrap it around
there
and then measure it and
his is about 36 and this should be about
one to two centimeters less than what
the head circumference was okay so that
wraps up this demonstration on how to
assess vital signs on an infant and be
sure to check out the other videos in
this Pediatrics series